mais avant de développer tous ces titres
nous allons à à bondy en région
parisienne pour une nouvelle
illustration de la violence en milieu
scolaire depuis hier tous les
enseignants et surveillants d'un collège
de sept vies sont en grève pour
protester contre l'agression d'un des
leurs reportages de juliette beau et
mathieu dreujou ce matin encore il n'y
aura pas classe au collège jean veil les
portes ne sont pas fermées mais les
élèves sont priés de rentrer chez eux
enseignants et surveillants assure un
accueil minimum excédé par la violence
quotidienne ils ne veulent plus
travailler
ils attendent des solutions concrètes et
tout de suite je trouve que lorsque des
enfants introduisent dans un
établissement scolaire du de l'acide de
l'essence mettent le feu à des portes
battantes provoque un incendie qu'il a
quand même fallu un quart d'heure à
éteindre les pompiers sont venus
lorsque des bombes explosent dans le
hall dans la cour on peut plus
travailler à chaque agression la police
vient sur les lieux enquête et
comparution immédiate se multiplient
mais depuis le mois de janvier
les actes de violence sont montés en
flèche en incident grave et signalé par
jour il se déroule au sein même de
l'établissement ou dans cette cour où
s'entassent les 750 élèves pendant les
récréations il y à peine un mètre carré
par adolescent je pense que si déjà il y
avait un peu moins de concentration des
enfants
ça devrait être un peu plus facile je
pense que si les parents reprennent dans
leur tête ou apprennent dans leur tête
ce qu'est être parents et non pas que ce
soit le grand frère qui viennent être
l'interlocuteur de l'équipe éducative
ici on aura fait un grand pas demain le
collège fermera ses portes
représentant de l'amérique de la police
et de l'éducation se réuniront en fin
d'après midi un conseil d'administration
extraordinaire pour discuter d'un
quotidien qui lui est bien ordinaire